There's no way Hugh Jackman could have known
he would wind up playing Wolverine in nine
films over nearly 20 years.
Especially since he only got the part as a
last-minute replacement.
A relative unknown at the time of his casting,
Jackman has used the part to launch a blockbuster
career, bringing legendary musicals to the
screen, hosting Oscar telecasts, and becoming
one of the most beloved faces Hollywood has
seen in decades.
"I'm Wolveriiiiine"
Now that he's delivered his X-Men swan song,
let's take a look back at the highs and lows
of his time as Wolverine and rank what worked—and
what made us go berserk.
X-Men Origins: Wolverine
There are bad movies, and then there's whatever
happened to X-Men Origins: Wolverine.
For starters, the movie just wasn't necessary.
Sure, the plot arc with Sabretooth was interesting,
but we didn't need a boxing match between
Logan and the Blob, and Logan's adamantium
operation had already been covered well enough
in X2: X-Men United.
On top of all that, X-Men Origins featured
the some of the worst CG in the entire franchise.
Wait, can we see those claws again?
"Ooh, shiny."
But more than anything, the sloppy writing
derailed any chance at redemption.
Not only did Wolverine have to walk away from
an explosion in slo-mo with a straight face,
but he also had to scream into the air not
once, but twice.
"Ah."
Here's a movie that introduced Ryan Reynolds
as Deadpool, then sewed his mouth shut, just
to make sure there was no chance he could
be remotely enjoyable.
"That's just lazy writing."
Jackman did his best with the corny screenplay,
but this movie is somehow a parody of itself
without ever figuring out how to make that
fun.
That's a feat, but not one worth watching.
X-Men: The Last Stand
The conclusion to the original X-Men trilogy
is so bad and so overstuffed, it almost ended
a franchise even Magneto couldn't bring down.
With Bryan Singer departing at the last minute
to helm Superman Returns, directing duties
for the third X-Men movie fell to Brett Ratner.
At best this movie is forgettable, at worst
it's a tutorial on how not to make a blockbuster.
If you can think of a character from the X-Men
universe, they probably show up here at some
point, spouting some awful catchphrase before
fading back into the special effects.
Or worse: Cyclops, who had been central to
the first two movies, is killed off early
and then never mentioned again.
Wolverine shows up, of course, but ends up
coming across as oddly neutered and bland.
"Grow those back."
And then there's the "Dark Phoenix" storyline,
a pivotal arc from the X-Men comics that gets
tossed into the plot with about seven other
stories.
Jackman did his best with the material, but
there was no saving this mutant monstrosity.
X-Men: First Class
He may not have had a part in the main story,
but Wolverine was definitely memorable in
X-Men: First Class, showing up to deliver
one line before disappearing for the rest
of the movie.
"Excuse me, I'm Eric Lechurr."
"I'm Charles Xavier."
"Go F--- yourself."
It may be short, even by cameo standards,
but it also may be the funniest scene Jackman
ever got to film as the surly superhero.
Although we can only imagine what he would
have said about those yellow jumpsuits.
"Do we really have to wear these?"
X-Men: Apocalypse
Unlike his brief cameo in First Class, Jackman's
appearance in X-Men: Apocalypse finally lets
Wolverine cut loose.
The Wolverine from the comic books has always
nurtured a darker side, which shows itself
in the peak of battle as his "berserker rage."
The mainstream movies shied away from this,
for the most part.
Thankfully, eight movies in, they finally
decided to cut him loose.
Back at the familiar setting of Alkali Lake,
which played a big part in Wolverine's origin
story, we see Weapon X as a caged animal,
finally getting a chance to fight for his
freedom.
It's a moment fans of the comics have waited
decades to see.
While the rest of the movie is sort of hectic,
Jackman's brief moment on the screen is a
revelation, and helped lay the groundwork
for what was to come.
X-Men: Days of Future Past
Wolverine can be such a tortured character
that it's all the more fun when he gets the
chance to just loosen up for a minute.
Trying to save the world seems like an odd
time to crack a smile, but while the stakes
are high, there's no doubt the tone in this
film is lighter than some of Wolvie's other
outings.
"Would you believe me if I told you I was
sent here from the future,"
Sure, fans of the comic can debate the decision
to swap out Kitty Pryde, who did all the time
traveling in the comic book storyline, but
sending Wolverine back in time instead was
a smart way to bridge the original and rebooted
X-Men casts.
X-Men
This is where it all started, and no one knew
if it could work.
What would a full-blown superhero team, full
of wacky powers, look like on the big screen?
Would they wear fluorescent spandex?
"You actually go outside in these things…?"
"What would you prefer.
Yellow spandex?"
More importantly, would audiences turn out
for comic book characters that weren't Superman,
Batman or Spider-Man?
With X-Men, those questions were definitively
answered.
It was faithful to the comics it adapted,
but used just enough black leather to welcome
mainstream audiences into the fold.
And no one helped carry the film, or captured
the imagination of the audience more, than
Jackman with his portrayal of Wolverine.
An amnesiatic drifter without a past or a
future, Wolvie was the audience's window into
this world of outcast and misfits.
If we found them weird, that was okay — because
he did too.
Jackman became a star the moment he appeared
on screen, and Wolverine proved he could brawl
with the best of them, spandex and all.
The Wolverine
Following the undeniable failure of X-Men
Origins: Wolverine, acclaimed director James
Mangold was brought in to clean up the Wolverine
franchise.
And for two-thirds of The Wolverine he did
just that, crafting a nuanced, intimate look
at Logan and drawing heavily on perhaps his
most celebrated comic book plotline: Chris
Claremont and Frank Miller's Wolverine limited
series.
By rooting the movie in his grief at the loss
of Jean Grey, and temporarily taking away
his healing power, this movie shows Wolverine
at his most vulnerable.
True, the third act then descended into the
typical bloat of a big-budget action movie,
with cartoonish robots and CGI-heavy fight
scenes.
But it showed that there were more Logan stories
to tell, especially if you stick to his source
material as closely as possible.
X2: X-Men United
The best standalone X-Men movie is without
a doubt X2: X-Men United, thanks largely to
its Wolverine-centered plot.
The franchise took this step forward by looking
to its past, specifically the mysterious background
of its most tortured hero.
By pitting Logan against William Stryker,
the man who coated Logan's bones with adamantium
and turned his memory into Swiss cheese, we
got to see a plot that was both personal and
explosive.
And its central set piece is perhaps the best
blend of action and emotion this franchise
has ever delivered, when babysitter Logan
hints at his beserker rage for the first time
onscreen.
"Babysitter?"
While the first X-Men movie set the stage,
this is what elevated the franchise into an
out-and-out hit.
Logan
It only took nine tries to get it perfect…but
boy, was it worth the wait.
This is the Wolverine we've all been waiting
for, a grizzled bastard who isn't looking
for a fight, but will definitely finish one
if it starts.
Loosely inspired by the acclaimed and influential
Old Man Logan arc, it tells the story of an
aged, grieving veteran of too many superhero
battles who wants to disappear—but gets
pulled back in one last time.
With a hard R rating that allows the blood
and guts Wolverine is famous for, nobody holds
back here.
Not the filmmakers, and not our hero.
Like a Johnny Cash song come to life, Logan
is both poetic and gritty — and it's one
of the best superhero movies ever made.
What's next?
Now that Jackman's Wolverine has been laid
to rest, fans have been speculating about
where the character will go next.
Considering Daphne Keen's show-stopping performance
as Laura in Logan, it's possible that she'll
become the next on-screen Wolverine — especially
since the same thing has happened in the comics.
But the comics also delve into a range of
other scenarios, from alternate universe Wolverines
to Logan himself coming back from the grave.
In other words, these are comic book movies.
Anything's possible.
As far as Jackman's concerned, he doesn't
particularly care who takes up the adamantium
mantle...with one exception.
As he jokingly told the New York Times, anyone
could become the new Wolverine, "unless Daniel
Day-Lewis plays him and wins the Oscar — then
I might have a little problem."
With the Fox-Disney merger on the horizon,
only time will tell what the future has in
store for Wolverine.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!